COOLING CENTERS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO KEEP YOU UP-TO-DATE.
STEVE AUTOPSIED ON TO YOU.
STEVE: ONE OF THE COUNTRY’S
BUSIEST SECTORS FOR BORDER
AGENTS HANDLING MIGRANT ACTIVITY
BUT THE 240-MILE DOLLAR REAL
STRETCH HAS A FRACTION OF THE
MANPOWER NEEDED TO PATROL IT.
THEY ONLY HAVE 12 AGENTS, ONLY
12 IS A FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND IT IS TAKEN A
SIGNIFICANT TOLL, ONE AGENT
CLAIMING MORALE IS LOW, EVERYONE
SHOWS UP TO WORK AND ALMOST DEAD
INSIDE, THEY’RE NOT ALLOWED TO
DO THE JOB AND THEY KNOW THAT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING AWAY
EVERYTHING GO THEY, EVERY SINGLE
HOUR, FORMER ICEFIELD DIRECTOR
FOR BUFFALO NEW YORK SAYS BIDEN
ORDER POLICY FORCED HIM TO STEP
ASIDE FROM HIS ROLE, HE QUIT AND
HE’S JOINING US ON THIS MONDAY
MORNING, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME.
STEVE: THE 240-MILE STRETCH ONLY
12 BORDER PATROL AGENTS, WHERE
IS EVERYBODY ELSE?
>> KEEP IN MIND THIS IS BY
DESIGN BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IF YOU’RE GONNA
PULL EVERYBODY OFF THE LINE TO
DO PROCESSING FOR THE INFLUX OF
ILLEGAL ALIENS THAT WE’VE HAD
SINCE JANUARY I’M NOT SURE WHAT
OCCURRED IN JANUARY TO MAKE THE
RUN TO THE UNITED STATES, WHEN
YOU PULL EVERYBODY OFF THE LINE
AND PUT 12 GUYS TO COVER
245 MILES, YOU’RE SENDING A
CLEAR SIGNAL TO THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND THAT YOU DO NOT CARE, YOU
DO NOT HAVE OUR BACK IN
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT IS NOT A
PRIORITY FOR YOU.
STEVE: EVERYBODY ELSE’S ENDORSED
PROCESSING THE PEOPLE WHO WENT
UP TO A PICKUP TRUCK AND
SURRENDER THEMSELVES AND SAID
CAN YOU PLEASE PROCESS ME.
WHAT IS MORALE LIKE DOWN IN THAT
SECTOR, IF YOU’VE ONLY GOT ONE
IN TEN FOR THE DEBORAH PEOPLE
THAT YOU NEED OUT ON THE LINE,
HOW DO THEY FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> MORALE IS REALLY LOW EVEN IN
REMOVAL OPERATIONS BECAUSE THERE
BEING DETAILED IN CBP BORDER
PATROL, IT IS LOW THESE ARE TYPE
A PERSONALITIES THAT BELIEVE IN
GOD AND COUNTRY AND TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND ENFORCE THE LAW
AND YOU TAKE A LARGE GROUP OF
MEN AND WOMEN LIKE THAT AND TELL
THEM THAT WE KNOW THIS IS WHAT
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS AND THIS
IS THE LAWS THAT WERE PASSED BY
CONGRESS AND SIGNED BY PRESIDENT
CLINTON IN 1996 BUT WE WANT YOU
TO LOOK THE OTHER WAY AND NOT DO
ANYTHING IN THERE AND HAVE A
HARD TIME WITH THAT.
STEVE: WE LOOK IN AND THERE’S
ONLY 12 AGENTS FOR 245 MILES, DO
YOU KNOW WHO LOVES THAT, THE
DRUG CARTELS THAT MEANS THE
CHANCES OF THEM GETTING THEIR
PAYLOAD INTO THE UNITED STATES
IS MUCH BETTER.
STEVE: I’M SURE IN THE NEAR
FUTURE WE WILL WANT TO KNOW
AGAIN WHERE ALL OF A SUDDEN ALL
CAME FROM AND I WAS TALKING TO
LOCAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN
WESTERN NEW YORK YESTERDAY AND
EVEN THEIR MORALE IS LOW,
THEY’RE DEALING WITH COVID AND
NOT BEING ABLE TO GET THE RIGHT
INFORMATION OUT BUT AGAIN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION PUTTING UP
THE ROADBLOCKS STOPPING OTHER
PROFESSIONALS FROM DOING WHAT
THEY SIGNED UP TO DO.
STEVE: THE ADMINISTRATION WANTS
FEWER GUYS AND GALS ON THE LINE?
>> ABSOLUTELY THIS IS ALL BY
DESIGN THEY TURNED OFF
EVERYTHING THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
TRIED TO DO IN PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS ON SECURING THE
BORDER THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY’RE DOING, THIS IS ALL BY
DESIGN THEY DON’T WANT THE
PORTABLE TO AGENTS ON THE BORDER
THEY WANT THEM INSIDE PROCESSING
WASTING TIME ON THE ILLEGAL
ALIENS INSTEAD OF TURNING THEM
AROUND AND SENDING THEM HOME.